So what is your why?
I mean, how many times do you hear somebody
ask you the question, "What's your why?"
Right?
And we say, well, I don't know what my why
- I think I'm doing this because I want to
do it for my family, or I want to be financially
free.
And so, this question is asked all the time.
So many of you message me and say, "Pat, I
want to find out about my why and what can
I do.
What is.
. . " So let's define what a why is.
First of all, anybody watching this - you
may not even know it - you all have a why.
Everybody has a why.
The challenge is that some people -- the majority
of people's why is, it doesn't graduate.
So your why needs to evolve.
What is evolve?
What is evolution of your why really mean?
It sounds a little bit too technical of a
topic to say the evolution of your why.
You know, Simon Sinek wrote the book, doesn't
it all start with your why?
Yes, it does all start with your why.
Of course it does, but a lot of times we don't
get to the next level of your why.
So today I want to talk to you about the evolution
of why, and then kind of challenge you on
the last level, and you'll see exactly what
I'm talking about with this.
So, everyone's why goes through four phases.
You first level of why is survival.
Let me explain what I mean by survival.
Everybody who has a job that makes money makes
money why?
To survive and pay bills.
But that is their why.
So unless you find a way to graduate that,
then it's the next level.
What's the next level?
You know, I want to make six figures.
Why?
Status.
I made six figures.
I have a nice car.
I have a house.
I have the same car, I'm having a good school,
I'm going to a place, I've got this, I've
got that.
So it's status.
Keeping up with the Joneses.
It's still lightweight.
But it's still a better why than survival.
The third one is freedom.
You know what?
I'm so sick and tired of six figures.
Man, I want to be free.
I want to make money.
I'm not worried about working hard, I want
to make money and I want to have freedom.
I want to have breathing room.
What do I need to do to have breathing room?
That's the next level.
Because then at that point you're not necessarily
doing it for somebody else.
You're doing it because your why has graduated.
You know what, I want to be free.
I want to live in that community because I
want my kids to play outside and not have
to worry about anything.
For me, I want to have a big back yard because
I want my kids to run around and not have
to worry about anything.
For me, for my family, I want to be free.
So this [freedom] is somewhat selfish.
Nothing wrong with it.
But it's not the highest level.
The highest level is purpose.
Now what are we talking about with purpose?
What is your why?
I'll talk to some people and they'll say,
my why is to one day own a football team.
[Shrug] That's still empty.
That's still empty.
I want to one day own a basketball team.
And people ask me, "Pat, are you one day going
to own a sports team?"
Of course.
That's in the plans.
If the opportunity comes, I think I'd make
a very good sports owner.
I'm fascinated by stats, sports, improvement,
competition.
It's fascinating.
But is that really the purpose of making billions
of dollars and making money?
No.
There's got to be a bigger purpose.
So how does one go from survival, status,
freedom, to purpose?
What is truly your purpose?
People ask, Pat, what's your purpose?
What is the bigger picture?
I can talk about that for an hour on what
my purpose is, but I'm driven by history.
But that didn't happen overnight.
You know, the saying goes, sometimes on the
way to a dream, you get lost and find a bigger
one.
A bigger dream.
You think it was all about the car.
You think it was all about the recognition.
You think it was all about the fame.
You think it was all about the status.
You think it was all about landing that girl.
You think it's all about all these other things,
but it's much bigger than that.
Then all of a sudden, one day you have a conversation
with somebody or watch a video, watch a movie
or meet someone that just boom, hits you in
the face and you say, wait a minute.
What the hell have I been thinking about?
I was put on this planet to do . . . Now you're
talking purpose.
Now you're talking purpose.
Very few people reach this level.
Why?
Very simple.
Too lazy to actually spend time thinking about
it.
They're afraid, what if I could do it?
And they don't process the issue well.
So they don't take time out to ask the question,
what do you really want to do with your life?
You know, what do you really want to do with
this?
I'm around a lot of different people.
A lot of different people.
And I'll sit there and have conversations.
"You know what?
I just partied with Jay Z last week."
And?
Jay Z's a human being.
You know, I just did this and I just did that.
I LOVE nice cars, because I love the history
and engineering.
I love it.
I've got an Ayrton Senna painting here.
I've got things from Ayrton Senna fans send
me all the time.
Why?
Because I'm fascinated by the guy died, on
I think May 3rd, 1994 from a race that he
was on.
It was either May 1st or May 3rd, 1994 at
the age of 34 years old, after being a three
time champion and he should have been four
time against Prost.
And his mom in a clip says, I'm just so proud
of my son because he's made us.
And you see him trying to wipe his tears.
And the day he won the race in Brazil.
He had never won in Brazil and he won the
race in Brazil and he can't pull up his shoulders
and he gets out, and he's asking for his dad,
asking for his dad and he hugs his dad and
said, "Dad, my shoulders are tight."
And he doesn't even know how to lift up the.
. I mean, that's emotional.
That's exciting to me.
That's fascinating to me.
For a human being to truly want to find out
what's their maximum capacity.
Where the entire country was emotional when
Senna died.
I mean, people said, we're one of the poorest
countries in the world.
We have nothing going on.
The only thing we had going on was Ayrton
Senna.
That's emotional.
That's purpose.
I want to make an impact that's bigger than
that.
But it only happens if you're actually willing
to sit down and ask some of the questions.
The important questions of life, and I think
unfortunately so many times you're just going,
going, going, going, going, so eventually,
you don't ask the important questions in life
until it's your funeral and it's already too
late.
And just so you know, about seven billion
people do this every 80 years.
I suggest you not be part of the seven billion.
You be part of the small community of people
that says, you know what?
Maybe I'm not going to start a company, but
I'm going to be part of a company and you
better believe that company's going to be
impacted because of what I'm going to do,
and one day I'm going to own a piece of that
company.
That's fine.
Maybe I'm going to be a founder.
Maybe we are going to take the money that
I'm making and I'm going to go back and teach
the world about entrepreneurship.
That's what I'm going to do.
Last level, level #4.
So, as you process this and go through it,
again, I'm doing a short video.
This is not a long video here.
You can ask yourself the question, but this
is the evolution of your why.
And don't you think it's time for you, as
you're watching this, to have your why evolve.
The only thing this happens is by self- interest.
You know, you've got to go through an inspection
of yourself and one of the things I've recommended
many people to do and use is the ultimate
self-discovery questionnaire.
The ultimate self-discovery questionnaire
changed my life.
It was in August 2003 where I went and took
these 83 questions; completely changed the
way I viewed life.
I was at the Matador Beach and I did a video
about this.
It's on my website, you can find it, 83 questions.
Let's put a link and the logo of the ultimate
self-discovery questionnaire here, where it's
at on the website.
And then click on the link below.
If you don't see any links here, what you
can always do is go back to PatrickBetDavid.com
and on PatrickBetDavid.com you will see the
link to the self-discovery questionnaire.
And last but not least, my buddy Mario here
just threw the pillow.
Subscribe to this channel.
The goal is to get to 100,000 subs.
Eventually we'll be at a million subs.
We feel this channel is the best channel for
entrepreneurs and we look forward to educating,
instructing, and giving many entrepreneurs
around the world clarity to take your business
to the next level.
So if you haven't subscribed to the channel,
please click on whatever the button's around
here -- it changes all the time on different
sites to subscribe to this YouTube channel.
Thank you everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.